i could eat could you eat because i  could always eat  here's something to hold us over  [Music]  hi i'm chef claus i'm going to show you  a sauce you can make in one minute  at home easy pieces the only thing you  need is four ingredients  this is mayo  you need a nice chunk this is  a hot sauce  and here is the sweet hot sauce you need  another spoon of that  and then you finish it up with some  chipotle smoked pepper  and this is going to taste amazing  you stir it and this is a sauce you  could leave in your refrigerator for  half an hour so the flavors come  together really good you can use it on  pretty much whatever you like to use it  on fish  meat sandwiches salads we actually  have a delicious chipotle aioli like  this on our own flatbread pizzas  sometimes all you need in your life is  to spice up  with a good sauce yum i cannot wait to  eat that  [Music]  you